STEVE: BREAKING TONIGHT,
PRESIDENT TRUMP WARNED IRAN THAT
I RAN 13 AMERICAN MOMENTS AGO
PRESENT FROM BEACON TO REPORTERS
AFTER RETURNING TO WASHINGTON
WAS STRONG WORDS TO EXPEL U.S.
TROOPS.
THE PRESIDENT SAYING QUOTE, WE
HAVE AN EXTRAORDINARY EXPENSIVE
AIRBASE THAT COST BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO BUILD, LONG BEFORE MY
TIME AND WE ARE NOT LEAVING
UNLESS THEY PAY US BACK FOR IT.
IF THEY DO ASK US TO LEAVE, IF
WE DON'T DO IT IN A FAMILY BASIS
WE WILL CHARGE THEM SANCTIONS
LIKE THEY'VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
IT WILL MAKE IRANIAN SANCTIONS
LOOKED SOMEWHAT TAME.
I THINK WE CAN AGREE CLASSIC
TRUMP THERE.
NEXT QUOTE.
WITH IRAQ WE SPENT MONEY AND A
ROCK AND I TOLD YOU IRAQ WAS THE
WORST DECISION GOING INTO THE
MIDDLE EAST WAS THE WORST
DECISION EVER MADE IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY IN IRAQ
DID NOT KNOCK DOWN THE WORLD
TRADE CENTER AND THAT'S BEEN
NICELY PROVEN BUT WE WENT IN AND
WE ARE THERE AND WE ARE PULLING
OUT.
PULLING OUT A LOT OF DIFFERENT
AREAS WITH SYRIA I PULLED OUT
BECAUSE OF NOT GOING TO GUARD
HIS BORDER.
WHY SHOULD I GUARD THEIR BORDER
THEY GOT TROOPS, LET THEM GUARD
THAT BORDER.
IT'S BEEN UNDER SIEGE FOR
THOUSANDS OF YEARS AND THEY BEEN
FIGHTING ON THAT BORDER.
MORE IN THAT VEIN FROM ME LATER
ON, AS EVIL SECRET WITH THIS AND
MORE COVERED FOR YOU WITH THE
LATEST NEWS AND THE SMARTEST
ANALYSIS WITH IN IN A MOMENT WE
GO TO A FORMER MARINE AND
CONGRESSMAN MIKE GALLAGHER.
BUT HERE WITH ME IS JASON
CHASE'S, TOMI LAHREN AND KATRINA
PEARSON.
HAPPY NEW YEAR EVERYONE AND
WELCOME TO THE NEXT REVOLUTION
ON STEVE HILTON AND THIS IS THE
HOME OF POSITIVE POPULISM, PRO-
WORKER, PROFAMILY, PRO-
COMMUNITY IN PRO- AMERICA BUT
ALSO IN THE SHOW TONIGHT MORE
GOOD NEWS ON THE ECONOMY.
MORE EMBARRASSMENT FOR JOE BIDEN
AND THE LOONY LEFT WE BRING YOU
THE STRANGE DEATH OF THE
REASONABLE DEMOCRAT, HOW EVEN
THE SO-CALLED MODERATES IN THE
PRESIDENTIAL RACE OUR WAY TO THE
LEFT AND IF ANYTHING WE'VE SEEN
BEFORE.
BUT FIRST I WANT TO LAY OUT FOR
YOU HOW I SEE THE ISSUES WITH
THIS WHOLE IRAN SITUATION.
OVER THE PAST FEW DAYS WE'VE
HEARD A LOT OF SUPERFICIAL
SIMPLISTIC AND SELF-SERVING
GRANDSTANDING ON THE USUAL
SUSPECTS.
TRUMP HATING DEMOCRATS AND THEIR
STOOGES IN THE RULING CLASS
STATE MEDIA HAVE MADE COMPLETE
FOOLS OF THEMSELVES AND WILDLY
INCONSISTENT POSITIONS.
APART FROM ONE THING, WHATEVER
TRUMP DOES IS BY DEFINITION
WRONG.
ONE OF THEIR FAVORITE TALKING
POINTS FOR DAYS WAS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP ACTIONS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL, ILLEGAL, AND
WITH THAT ARGUMENT WAS DESTROYED
THIS MORNING BY PRESIDENT
OBAMA'S HOMELAND SECURITY
SECRETARY JAKE JOHNSON.
>> IF YOU BELIEVE EVERYTHING
THAT OUR GOVERNMENT IS A SAYING
ABOUT QASSEM SOLEIMAN HE WAS A
LAWFUL MILITARY OBJECTIVE AND
THE PRESIDENT UNDER HIS
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY AS
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF HAD AMPLE
DOMESTICALLY LEGAL AUTHORITY TO
TAKE HIM OUT WITHOUT AN
ADDITIONAL CONGRESSIONAL
AUTHORIZATION.
WHETHER HE WAS A TERRORIST OR A
GENERAL IN A MILITARY FORCE THAT
WAS ENGAGED IN ARMED ATTACKS
AGAINST OUR PEOPLE HE WAS A
LAWFUL MILITARY OBJECTIVE.
>> I SHOULD APOLOGIZE FOR NBC'S
SOUND PROBLEMS THERE BUT YOU GET
THE POINT.
THE AWARD THE MOST HUMILIATING
IDIOCY OF THE WEEK PROBABLY GOES
TO DEMOCRAT SENATOR CHRIS MURPHY
WHO ON TUESDAY AFTER THE U.S.
EMBASSY IN BAGHDAD WAS ATTACKED
BEFORE THE STRIKE SAID THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP
"-RIGHT-DOUBLE-QUOTE RENDERED
AMERICA IMPOTENT JUST HOPING
THAT GUYS GO AWAY BUT WHEN THAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENED WHEN ONE OF
THE BAD GUYS INDEED ONE OF THE
WORST GUYS IN THE WORLD DID IN
FACT GO AWAY AS A DIRECT RESULT
OF PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ACTION,
MURPHY CRITICIZED IT LITERALLY
COMPLAINING ABOUT THE FACT THAT
QASSEM SOLEIMAN HAD BEEN TAKEN
OUT.
HE WAS NOT THE ONLY ONE WITH
EVER SINCE DONALD TRUMP WON THE
ELECTION HIS OPPONENTS HAVE LOST
THEIR MIND AND WITH ANY ABILITY
TO MAKE A COHERENT ARGUMENT.
IF TRUMP'S FORTE, THEY ARE
AGAINST IT.
LOOK AT THEIR POLICY.
WHAT'S ON THE MIDDLE EAST.
ALL OF IT DRIVEN BY ANTI- TRUMP
HATE.
WHEN HE PULLED BACK FROM THE
MIDDLE EAST IT WAS A DISASTER.
>> TRUMP HAS BROKEN AMERICA'S
SOLEMN PROMISE TO THOSE WHO
SACRIFICED SO MUCH ON OUR BEHALF
SPIRIT I'M TIRED OF TRUMP
WRAPPING HIMSELF IN THE FLAG IN
THE MORNING AND ABANDONING OUR
TROOPS AND VALUES BY THE
AFTERNOON.
>> I WOULD NOT ABANDON THE
TROOPS OR WITHDRAWN THE THOUSAND
TROOPS IN IRAQ.
>> YESTERDAY ON THE FLOOR 350
MEMBERS VOTED IN A BIPARTISAN
WAY TO OPPOSE THE PRESIDENT
DANGEROUS DECISION IN REGARD TO
SYRIA.
>> )-RIGHT-PARENTHESIS GOT THAT.
GETTING OUT IS DANGEROUS SO
DANGEROUS.
WAIT.
SO IS GOING IN.
>> PRESIDENT'S DECISION MAY ADD
TO AN ALREADY DANGEROUS AND
DIFFICULT SITUATION IN THE
MIDDLE EAST.
>> WE ARE GOING TO END UP IN
ESCALATIONS, MILITARY ESCALATION
AROUND THE WORLD.
>> WE APPEAR TO BE, WITHOUT BY
THE WAY, WITHOUT CONGRESSIONAL
AUTHORIZATION AND CLINGING TO
ANOTHER MIDDLE EAST WARS.
>> THEY HAVE TAKEN A STEP THAT
MOVES US CLOSER TO WAR.
IT'S A STEP THAT PUTS EVERYONE
AT RISK.
STEVE: THEY HAVE NO COHERENT
POSITION.
THEY HAVE NO STRATEGY.
THEY HAVE MORE OF WHAT THEY GAVE
US WHEN THEY HELD THE WHITE
HOUSE.
APPEASEMENT, WEAKNESS AND
ESTABLISHMENT PREDICTABILITY.
IT'S EXACTLY WHAT KEPT US IN
THESE AND LESS COSTLY STUPID
WARS WE'VE ALSO SEEN SIMPLISTIC
KNEE-JERK NONSENSE FROM THE
ISOLATION AND NUTS.
WHAT IS TRUMP DOING?
HE PROMISED TO GET OUT OUT OF
ORBIT WE SHOULD NOT INTERVENE
ABROAD.
YOU KNOW THE SCRIPT.
IT'S EASY ENOUGH TO LUXURIATE IN
SUPPOSED TO IDEOLOGY AND
SUPERFICIAL SLOGANS BUT IN THE
REAL WORLD AN AMERICAN PRESIDENT
CAN'T JUST DISENGAGE FROM THE
WORLD FOR THE VERY OBVIOUS
REASON THAT WHAT HAPPENED IN
OTHER COUNTRIES HAS AFFECTED US
HERE AND THAT IS WHY WE CARE
ABOUT TRADE DEALS FOR EXAMPLE
AND THEY AFFECT US HERE AT HOME
AND YES, THAT IS WHY WE CARE
ABOUT PROJECTING MILITARY POWER
ABROAD.
THE QUESTION IS NOT WHETHER WE
SHOULD INTERVENE INTERNATIONALLY
BUT HOW.
AMERICA FIRST DOESN'T MEAN
AMERICA ALONE, NOR DOES IT MEAN
AMERICA STAYS AT HOME.
IT MEANS AMERICA'S POLICIES,
DOMESTIC AND FOREIGN, SHOULD BE
DETERMINED BY WHAT IS BEST FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE
ISOLATION NUTS DON'T SEEM TO
UNDERSTAND THAT.
THEY TAKE A STAND AGAINST ANY
INTERNATIONAL ACTION EVEN WHEN
IT IS IN AMERICA'S INTEREST.
NEXT, THEY WILL WANT US OUT OF
THE OLYMPICS BECAUSE OF THE
FOREIGN COMPETITION.
SPEAKING OF INTERNATIONAL
COMPETITION THE OTHER BUNCH OF
USUAL SUSPECTS WHO POOPED OFF
AGAINST THE QASSEM SOLEIMAN
STRIKE ARE THE EUROPEANS,
BRITISH AND GERMAN HAVE
EXPRESSED THEIR GREAT CONCERN
AND CALLING FOR RESTRAINT.
YOU BET THEY ARE PAID THEY ARE
STILL TRYING TO REVIVE THE
ROTTEN CORPSE OF THE IRAN
NUCLEAR DEAL WHICH FUNNELED
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS DIRECTLY TO
QASSEM SOLEIMAN TO FUND TERROR
AND MAYHEM THROUGHOUT THE MIDDLE
EAST.
THE BRITISH ARE NOW IN A PANIC
OVER THEIR ENERGY IMPORTS.
SENDING NAVY SHOOTS SHIPS TO
GUARD TINKERS IN THE GOLF
BECAUSE THEY'VE ALLOWED
THEMSELVES TO BECOME DEPENDENT
ON ENERGY IMPORTS AND
UNBELIEVABLY, DESPITE ESTIMATES
THAT FRACKING CAN HELP THE UK
TOWARDS ENERGY INDEPENDENCE THE
BRITISH GOVERNMENT HAS ABANDONED
AND THAT IS NEATLY BRINGS US TO
THE REAL STORY HERE.
AS WE REPORTED A FEW WEEKS AGO
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN HISTORY,
THANKS TO PRESIDENT TRUMP'S PRO
ENTERPRISE AGENDA, AMERICA HAS
JUST BECOME A NET EXPORTER OF
OIL AND GAS THE TRUTH IS OIL HAS
BEEN THE DRIVING FORCE FOR THE
WESTERN INVOLVEMENT IN THE
MIDDLE EAST FOR OVER A CENTURY.
IT DROVE BRITISH IMPERIALISM AND
AMERICAN IMPERIALISM AND THE
INEVITABLE RESENTMENT THAT
FOLLOWS.
IT'S DRIVEN BY THE ENERGY
IMPERATIVE THAT THE WEST HAS
TRIED TO REMAKE AND RESHAPE THE
MIDDLE EAST CREATING NOTHING BUT
A COSTLY BLOODIED DISASTROUS
MESS.
ALONG THE WAY THE ESTABLISHMENT
IN WASHINGTON HAS CASHED IN WITH
SOME OF THE MOST OBSCENE
CORRUPTIONS OF THE MODERN ERA.
VICE PRESIDENT MACK CHENEY
PUSHING A CATASTROPHIC INVASION
THAT PUTS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
INTO THE POCKETS OF HIS FORMER
COMPANY HALLIBURTON.
JOE BIDEN'S BROTHER CASHING IN
JUST LIKE SO MANY IN THE SWAMP
AND THE MILITARY-INDUSTRIAL
COMPLEX AND THE ASTONISHMENT WHO
ARE ADDICTED TO ENDLESS WAR IN
THE MIDDLE EAST.
NOW WE SEE THE SAME GENIUSES IN
THE SWAMP THING TAKES AND
INSTITUTES FOR STRATEGIC
WHATEVER GREATLY EXPRESSING
THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT HOW
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ACTIONS WILL
HAMPER THE PROSPECTS OF THE
MIDDLE EAST PISTE IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST ISIS OR SOME OTHER
ILLUSORY GOAL.
WHAT PLANET ARE THEY ON AND THEY
ARE ARE NO PROSPECTS IN THE
MIDDLE EAST PEACE AS LONG AS WE
ARE THERE.
WE NEVER WILL DEFEAT THE
IDEOLOGY OF ISLAMIC TERROR AS
LONG AS ALL THESE COUNTRIES ARE
BASKET CASES BUT ONE OF THE MAIN
REASONS THEY ARE BASKET CASES IS
THAT OUR PREPOSTEROUS FOREIGN
POLICY ESTABLISHMENT IS
MONUMENTAL ARROGANCE TREATED THE
MIDDLE EAST LIKE SOME CHESS
GAME.
SPLAYED OUT IN THE BORDERS OF
WASHINGTON AND LONDON BUT THEY
ARE A JOKE.
NOTHING THEY EVER PROPOSED HAS
EVER WORKED.
EVERYTHING HAS FAILED.
THE WEST INVOLVEMENT IN THE
MIDDLE EAST HAS BEEN A DISASTER
FROM THE START FINALLY WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP AMERICA ISN'T A
A POSITION TO BRING IT TO AN END
WE DON'T NEED THAT OIL AND WE
DON'T NEED THEIR PROBLEMS.
FINALLY WE HAVE A U.S. PRESIDENT
WHO GET THAT AND WANTS TO GET
OUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN DOING
NOTHING BUT IT MEANS INTERVENING
ONLY IN WAYS THAT HELP AMERICA.
IT MEANS RESPONDING TO ATTACKS
ON AMERICAN DISPROPORTIONATELY
AS A DETERRENT JUST AS WE SOUGHT
THIS WEEK.
IT MEANS PULLING OUT OF MISSIONS
THAT ARE DOOMED TO FAILURE AS WE
THOUGHT THE OTHER MONTH WITH
SYRIA.
IT MEANS FINALLY ACCEPTING THAT
IT IS NOT OUR JOB TO FIX THE
RELEASED FROM AFAR BUT TRYING TO
DO SO HAS BEEN VANDALIZED THE
WHOLE REGION IN THE BEST THING
AMERICANS CAN DO IS TO PUT THE
MIDDLE EAST ON A PATH THAT LEADS
TO MORE DEMOCRACY, LESS
TERRORISM, HUMAN RIGHTS AND
ECONOMIC GROWTH IS TO GET THE
HELL OUT OF THERE.
WE ALSO NEED TO SHOW AN
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL YOUR
DETERMINATION TO DEFEND AMERICAN
INTERESTS WITH FORCE WHEREVER
THEY ARE THREATENED.
THE REAL THREAT TO AMERICA IS
NOT IRAN OR ANYTHING ELSE COMING
OUT OF THE MIDDLE EAST BUT
CHINA, THE REAL STRENGTH OF
AMERICA IS ALWAYS UNDERWRITTEN
BY A STRONG ECONOMY AND THAT
MUST ALWAYS BE THE PRIORITY.
I BELIEVE PRESIDENT TRUMP
UNDERSTANDS THAT AND IF HE
STICKS TO THAT STRATEGY HE WILL